Whenever a website
shows user's input,
you need to be
careful and vigilant.
A user's input can be anything
and it is your responsibility
to make sure it won't
break your site.
A clueless user might
break it by accident,
an evil techer might
exploit this flaw
and make your website do things
that it did not intend at all.
Not validating user input is one
of the oldest vulnerabilities
on the web and is called
cross-site scripting or XSS
for short.
The name comes from the
fact that JavaScript
can be injected into
another site where
it gets executed and has access
to all of its site's data.
A typical example is a website
that asks for a user's name
when they want to
leave a comment.
If this input is not
validated, a user's name
can be crafted in
such a way that it
contains JavaScript code.
That means that every
user reading that comment
will only see the
name, but the code
will be executed without
the user's knowledge.
In the grand scheme of
things, this example
here is rather harmless.
But the script has access
to all of the site's data,
including the dom and cookies.
It could even make
fetch requests
from the site's origin.
A well-crafted XSS exploit
can be detrimental.
The only way you
can secure yourself
against these
kinds of attacks is
to follow a golden rule
that always applies
in software engineering,
validate your user's input
server [? site. ?]